he did it one to her she got mad at him
get away and so that they had like it oh
oh get yah yah yah yah Minnie Parker
yeah oh [ __ ] you
back stayin [ __ ] [ __ ] anyways when I
got the intro before the little title
card
we shall rue they were they see me I'm
signaling I'm doing everything that's
within the law no I think it's
definitely tough I I was never like
bullied as a kid in high school was
everybody yeah you lucky B that's cuz
you were the bully huh yes you are you
were dancing around everybody's up [ __ ]
oh no I wasn't pulling in high school I
was I wouldn't say I'm bullied now but
like I definitely started getting a lot
more negativity once I started YouTube
which is a terrible thing to think but I
mean when people are behind their
keyboards they can say anything they
want and most of the time I figured out
because they just want some attention
sometimes I feel like I hate you so much
why do they even have a channel then
when you finally replied like oh I just
wanted to see who I love you so much
bubble blah and you're like ah now I
like [ __ ] free so sick [ __ ] super
yeah that's why I don't like to give
negative comments too much attention
because the people that are giving so
many positive ones are like oh we're not
getting anything from supporting you
you're only paying attention to people
that are giving you crap even when
people like if I write something very
serious back to them like yo don't even
worry about this [ __ ] don't waste your
time on them it's like [ __ ]
first of all that's my time I wasted how
I felt
I gotta say that I can't hold this in
it's like holding it a sneeze like I
gotta let you know how stupid you are
yeah I have to cuz I type it and then I
go about my day I don't talk about it
again just or like you stupid
I get this is gonna be very confession
for this car um I used to have a
snaggletooth quite a few snaggle teeth I
should say plural um mother [ __ ] you
would have a popular in Japan they love
that [ __ ] dude Japanese people of weird
shared life of all your teeths to screw
up yo you've been a hot commodity I'm
the why you fixing I got a few of those
and I got in midline cuz I just couldn't
take it like I was very insecure when I
first started and it was so tough to be
like how am I gonna be myself on this
camera when anyone anyone can see is not
what I'm saying but my screwed up teeth
so I got Invisalign like things like
that like really bothered me now it's a
bit better but yeah thing is they're
like I really taste the snaggletooth
that's nothing cuz the rest of the
canvas is great it's just one thing no I
mean I have an astigmatism in my eyes
when people love to comment on that as
well
people can see astigmatism in your eyes
yeah it's like they're like what do you
have a lazy eye I'm like actually yeah
so do I because I used to be really
negative and so like I think it's just
too tiring to me like that what was the
switch didn't fear like I'm done being
negative like how did you it just wasn't
like conducive to what I was doing like
mind you here's my opinion on people
with problems so well if you've noticed
especially in Hollywood people with the
most money complete the most you know I
could just too much free [ __ ] time
you have too much free [ __ ] time to
worry about [ __ ] that you're not
supposed to be worried about my parents
didn't complain about [ __ ] mind you my
mom was working 80-hour weeks at her
business right my dad was a full-time
pastor too at a church he was going
through seminary school and he had two
kids and we were broke as [ __ ]
they've never complained mmm never
complain you don't have time to complain
about stupid [ __ ] yeah that's why I hate
words like Oh universe what do you want
me to do my [ __ ] your universe they're
like what the [ __ ] is the universe just
worry about your [ __ ] and just live life
how you're supposed to you know and I
think when you have free time to
complain as you're already [ __ ] up so
I always tell kids to like if you're
waking up every morning and then the
first thing you do is find something
wrong which we wrong with yourself then
you've already [ __ ] up for the rest of
the day yeah so like when you wake up be
happy with yourself and let the whole
world like try to [ __ ] you up so you
can't be the first source of negativity
right and so we're the you know you know
one bothered you
1:5 was gorgeous there is quite a few
your 14 piece volume McKenna 14 it's
hard when you're like looking at
yourself when you're editing and you're
like oh this looks bad this looks done
it's so easy to take yourself down which
is why I'm gonna try your your theory or
wake up and tell something about myself
dude I'm telling you right now if I look
like you I'd be a [ __ ] so I don't
understand but still a guy but looking
like me or being a girl I'd be a girl I
would [ __ ] it up so fast that's so weird
because girls are so particle of
themselves okay I'm cellulite Sally look
at my huge four donkey now who could
have said that oh yeah it's Tina that
talking to me it'd be so quick like dude
I know it's tough but here's the thing
okay being a girl is difficult and you
want to know what I'm sure you already
know why look if you just look anywhere
right now you can see all the
advertisements that is given to girls to
look a certain way or to eat a certain
food or to be this or be that it's like
this it starts with Barbie dolls are you
kidding no one's going to look like that
except if you pay a million dollars plus
to get plastic surgery to look like
Barbie but like even I mean I'm a victim
of this to like highlighting and
contouring like that should blew up and
I love I do it I like it but I feel like
it makes me prettier and I think a lot
of other people do too
and I think there was even an article
where like girls clothes were like a
couple more dollars than guys clothes
like just a red polo at like a gap or
something was like five bucks this is a
really teacher five bucks it probably
wasn't gap and then a guy sure it was
like 250 like the same exact shirt want
to just market it for girls because we
are bigger consumers in the beauty
industry that's so interesting July
that's crazy I mean I know obviously I
don't know what a girl goes through I
think like for me too because you know
if in fact you know I have a kid and I
get a daughter like one of my biggest
goals is for whether I guess for pizzazz
specifically as a girl is for her to
appreciate like her own beauty yeah cuz
it is true like you do get a lot of [ __ ]
for just being like for example like you
know one of the things that I do dislike
it might go counter to it to what you're
saying but when guys say this concept
it's like I love it when a girl wears no
makeup and they're false because they
say that but they don't act it out yeah
does it [ __ ] matter so increase more
insecurities right you know what I mean
so it's book that's why I drank [ __ ]
irritates the [ __ ] enemy sometimes he
says all this [ __ ] that you know for
a fact he doesn't believe deal with no
[ __ ] bond
yeah I love it we got boogers in your
nose copy gratitude yeah
which it's good I mean it's decent like
but the thing is when you heat there or
I imagine when you eat like a lot of
vegan
type foods which actually isn't it
anyways I'll get back to that later but
you eat it and you're like really full
but then you feel kind of empty it's
about a hot kind which we get inside
yeah yeah it's like a fake out like oh
I'm so full